um my name is bildas um I work as a data
scientist at exil um in New York City um
for um this presentations you could um
ask me any questions comment feedback um
to B
m.edu um if you are interested in um
latest machine learning news um papers
um software open source software you
could also sign up uh the machine
learning newsletter that I create weekly
at
ml. um as I already mentioned the
IPython notebooks that I will be going
through this tutorial is um is in this
link um this will open up a um GitHub
repo which you could clone um fork and
um U make modifications on top of it um
so uh I'll be going through um this uh
IPython notebooks um for the um first we
will start with h basic supervisor
learning uh problem and the cross
validation and then we will um switch to
the parameter search um by using G
search and uh randomized parameter
search in psychic learn then um psych
learn has a pipeline U module which
provides you um to combine different um
machine learning steps uh into one
single um object uh and makes it uh very
convenient to use and I'll talk a little
bit about distant functions and soring
functions then um there is also another
uh subm module uh in the psy learn
feature unions I'll be uh talking about
that and then generalization model
selection out of core learning um if you
cannot fit the data into the memory um
psychic learn also provides a way to
handle um those learning problems um we
may not uh do the deployment uh but on
Sunday there's another talk um by rahad
I think uh which uh in which he will
talk about it so we could um safely SK
skipped that step for the language
detector um this is like an extra
IPython notebook you could follow it
along um there is like um uh there's a
um language classifier in there which um
tries to predict um the language based
on the text input um that user
enters so the first so the first IPython
notebook um just shows the um versions
of the libraries if you have the latest
Anaconda um installation um these U
versions should be uh satisfied um this
is um the this is my kind of um original
setup sorry about
that um but any um newer version um
should be uh good to
go and let's start with
the I'm sorry
s sure sure
sure um yeah I could put that
actually thank you
sure
maybe I could
the
yep
um hopefully everybody's um set up his
environment um so let's start um so the
first uh problem in the machine learning
maybe most research most um kind of uh
spend time on it is the supervised
learning problem uh it comes with a two
different um types of problem one of
them is regression one of them is
classification classification from
regression in the sense that
classification tries to uh output or
yield a discrete label whereas
regression tries to Output a um
continuous variable if you want to kind
of classify um if a user will be turned
or not based on some um based based on
usage of some service or some product
that uh corresponds to uh a
classification problem because it is
either one or zero whereas a regression
problem uh could involve with uh the
trying to predict a house uh price based
on house attributes um house price uh
may not um house price could be anything
um from starting from zero to up to some
finite number uh but classification
requires uh discret labels um in this
data set uh we have a CH problem um we
have a bunch of um usage
data um a length International PL
voicemail plan and also um we have um
usage as well like total KN calls total
KN charge um International minut used
and we have also some other um
attributes as well number of customer
service calls made um you could kind of
consider um this um attribute uh maybe
the most predictive one because if the
customer is not happy about the service
or the product then uh he's or she's
likely to um make a lot of calls to the
service U because uh he's not happy
about it um so um we will try to uh
predict um based on user data either one
or zero um based on the attributes
earlier um this is called binary
classification since we have only two
labels um and um we are trying to label
um the output as one or zero um it is
binary
output um in general I um load the data
with pandas and then try to preprocess
it um in pandas as well and then uh
switch to the N array and then Cy learn
um pandas makes it easy to use um for
categorical variables and other type of
data that are not necessarily uh in
numbers um since we cannot really use
those data um without converting to the
um without converting to um into numbers
uh we need to do preprocessing for
example in here we have State uh which
is categorical variable um even like
churn um the label is actually a string
uh um even if it looks like a bullying
variable so um in order to um preprocess
the
um in order to convert the categorical
variable into discret integer values Psy
learn provides a preprocessing subm
module um which has a class label
encoder and you could uh create a um
object based on that and then um you
could feed the uh label encoder with the
state information and then the DF state
becomes a discret integer value um in
order to get the um out in order to get
the output labels as one or zeros um we
are also doing some pre processings in
here and then
um and then in here I am dropping the um
kind of redundant or not necessarily
um uh useful information for example Fon
information is not very straightforward
to reason about if a customer will be
churned or not and since we are actually
capturing the churn information into
this y Matrix we are also um dropping
the ch um CH attributes in the data
frame as well
and then this is just for uh to get the
U to get uh integers since these are all
string values we want to get the um
integers and when we look at the class
distribution in here um we have an
unbalance data problem because we have
um only 483 instance for CH class and um
like six times more not CH classes uh
this will create a problem uh later when
we try to the
classifier um and then um after that uh
everything is nicely formatted uh we
have um numbers uh for each attributes
false and true we don't have to do uh
anything because buing are represented
as integers under the in Python and when
we um when we pass the MP flood um these
false and truths will be converted into
um zeros and
on and then uh we built the future
Matrix of X um the uh uppercase X
actually is what psyit learn use as
convention so I will be following this
psyit learn convention this is um kind
of the feature metrix that we will be
using um to learn uh which features are
more important comparing to the um y u
metrix which has the um which has the
output labels that we comput in
here um and then uh up to this point um
we are not done yet though uh because if
you look at it um some attributes uh may
be varying uh between zero and uh 50
some attributes are just uh bulling
variables which just vary between zero
and one um and if we just use as it is
um then we are actually biased towards
the the features that have high number
of uh values comparing to the um
comparing to the uh attributes that have
um lower values and in order to um kind
of mitigate that problem we will be
using a standard scaler um pyit learn
provides a lot of different um scalers
the standard scaler is one of the um
most commonly used and also is one of
the simp simplest one it um subtract the
mean uh from the features and then um
divides by standard deviation so at the
end of it um um it is guaranteed that
you you would have a feature Vector for
each um single attribute that has a mean
of zero and the U standard deviation um
uh is one um and then after this
producing this Matrix um the feature
Matrix is kind of ready to be ready to
be put into a classifier or um to be put
into the psych learn model that we could
um learn but before that than that um
there is another concept uh cross
validation which is um quite important
if we have um 10 different um kind of uh
faults in the training set this is the
whole data if we train the classifier on
all the 10 fults and then try and then
the look at the accuracy the accuracy
number would be overly optimistic
because this is like um we are going to
learn all of these 10 folds and then
after learning all of the 10 TFS we will
evaluate the the classifier based on uh
the fals that we learned um which
produces an um overl optimistic number
and
um uh and it it doesn't necessarily
convert into the test accuracy so
instead um there is um the cross
validation provides a structure that you
would um train your classifier into 9
folds and then evaluate on the
validation set and then uh we could do
this based on if you are dividing the
training set 10 faults um you could get
the in the round to the second um fault
as a validation set and so on and then
after after that since these uh
validation sets are not used in the
training process this uh average
validation accuracy actually provides a
much uh more accurate um final accuracy
that could be actually converted to the
test score because at the end of the day
when we um kind of train the classifier
uh there is this test set we don't have
any knowledge of we we are actually
trying to kind of reproduce the same um
same uh same procedure we will um do
nine training and then we have no idea
about this validation set and then we
try to predict EV validation accuracy in
the test set we would do the same thing
we would train the classifier in the
temp folds and then uh and then look at
the test accuracy of the data that we
have no knowledge of um
in um cyc learn uh there's a cross
validation subm module uh where you
could um kind of create a stratified
Kult objects um stratification is if you
have um a unbalance data problem um like
we do in here you want to make sure that
the um you wouldn't end up with a fault
that has only the CH class so if if you
have only the CH class in this
validation set and then uh not not turn
class in here for this 9 F and when you
train the classifier in here the the
classifier has a bias of not turn class
and then since the this round would be
only the um this validation set would
have the only turn class then the um
validation accuracy would be uh Overland
um like it wouldn't be very accurate
because the class distributions are not
um same across each fault um in order to
mitigate that you need to uh also
stratify the labels um so that the every
fault needs to have the same
distribution of the labels both CH and
um notr class um this stratifi CV um is
a kind of a repper on stratified Kult um
where you could kind of provide the x
and y and then um tries to do stratify
CV on top of it and then um outputs the
by predictions if you look at the um
accuracy scores um um um using a bunch
of different models uh after we built
this um cross validation and then um we
could look at the matrix. accuracy score
uh in the psych learn which provides a
um the difference between Y and Y
prediction uh like y prediction um over
y over um total number of the length of
the Y then we would get um we we would
get quite High uh accur es but if we
build a um you know dump class fire that
predicts all the time zero um for every
y we get actually pretty good um
accuracy as well because um in the in
the ambalance side the unturned class is
actually 86% of the class so this is not
very um really useful um if you just
look at the uh accuracy score you may be
uh kind of um you may think that these
classifiers are really good but uh
indeed it is not the
case so uh for those cases confusion
matrices are um really nice way to
visualize your um kind of error
distribution in the class I have this um
you know um
sure so um this you asking um class are
unbalanced
mhm sure um
so um so let's assume we have 90% of um
not CH class in the training set and 10%
CH class if we do the cross validation
based on just you know um random
splitting 90 and 10% then it might be
the case that the training set may have
the
um not CH class and then the validation
set would have only the CH class so
since this is like the 10% of the whole
class when you train this classifier
into the 90% And then try to predict in
here 10% then since this classifier saw
only the not turn class labels then the
output of the uh CH class wouldn't be
very
meaningful because you are only training
on the on on on the not CH instances and
you try to predict CH instances in the
validation set so you need to kind of
distribute both CH set and also not CH
set into each faults so that uh you so
that each fault would have the same
distribution 90% of CH instances and 90%
of not not CH instances and 10% um CH
instances across each fault so that you
would have a much better or um accurate
um accuracy uh at the end of the
day in uh if you have like a a balanced
data set you know 50% of um 1 50% on
zero you don't have to necessarily care
about the stratification because even if
you um do random split then uh this
Faults Are will share the 50% of uh one
and 50% of the zero doesn't that problem
go away if your data large enough um not
necess not necessarily because because
um um then you true yeah that's true
yeah if if you have but if you have very
large data set then yeah that problem
goes away because stratification
actually does the same thing when you
randomly split then you would have each
fault uh would have the 90% And 10%
distribution this
yep but still you could um use
stratified Kult to make sure that you
know those labels have the same same
distribution of the overall data set um
there's no harm on
that so the um um so we found out that
the accuracy score is not very uh useful
so let's look at the confusion matrices
confusion Mates is like um so what which
class has the most um you know uh has
the best predictions for example or
maybe I could just first show the Dum
classifier what we are doing in here for
example in here we have
2850 instances of n class and we are
always predicting uh uh the nutr class
and this is completely correct but since
we are not uh predicting any uh CH class
then we have in here one and once zeros
whereas since we are uh predicting only
zeros we have this uh error
483 which is really bad because at the
end of the day we actually want to maybe
capture most of here because that is the
most value in in there maybe we could be
um maybe we could be okay with in here
some of the classes some of the not CH
instances may be labeled as CH and then
those customers would get more Focus
even if they they don't but in here we
don't really we we want to basically
minimize this a number because this this
number would be the most misclassified
uh trans classes and these customers
will go away so if you look at the other
classifiers and um what they are doing
on the CH for example paf aggressive
classifier are not really uh doing a
terrible um doing a really good job in
here but we have uh gradient boosting
which captures most of the um most of
the CH classes pretty well um it errors
in in here a little bit maybe this
number is not very uh very good but
still um it it could be considered
okay
um and um we have also random Forest uh
which is relatively good as well um
these random force and gradient boosting
in here uh was also really good in the
accuracy score but unless we um
visualize the confusion matrices and uh
see the where the error is um then um we
can't really um reason about unless we
visualize this confusion matrices
because the dump classifier has 86% of
accuracy as well and um if you want to
do um like this type of error analysis
in confusion matrices there is also U
accuracy precision recall F1 scores
which actually um kind of compares the
true positive through negative ratio
over uh each metric and then tries to
produce a um tries to tries to produce a
kind of combined score which could be
much more meaningful than a uh let's say
a um
then in accuracy score and um psych
learn has a metrix subm module which
outputs this uh classification report in
a string format and then you could look
at the uh each labels precision and
recall for example um let's look at our
Dum classier it Precision is pretty good
um because this is the percentage of the
uh not CH classes and recall we are
already capturing all of it and F1 score
for this zero is pretty good as well but
overall the Precision and recall for the
CH class is pretty terrible um when you
look at the random force and gradient
boosting for example these numbers are
all all around High um for example in
gradient boosting um since we have less
number of instances um for the CH class
0.92 means that the total number of CH
classes we could uh when we say one we
are uh 92%
precise but overall uh in the data set
we could only capture the
74% uh of the uh of the CH class we
could only label those so the overall uh
the total accuracy for this one 92 is
the uh 92% is the ones that we could
kind of label properly and then 74% is
what we kind of recall uh from the whole
data set um if you if you kind of
consider this uh precision and recall in
a search engine setting uh when Google
brings some results onto the first page
um the Precision would be the total
number of relevant results to you over
the um total number of results in the
first page for example when you search
for machine learning um Google brought
to eight relevant links uh that means
Precision is uh over 10 8 over 10 8% but
for the recall uh if it brings you 3
million web pages and if there is 4
million web pages in the web that is
about machine learning then the recall
is
75% um in the search engines generally
they try to optimize uh Precision
because a user could only see so many
web pages or so many um pages that the
uh search engines bring but in uh recall
is also uh quite important for other
settings F1 score is uh just the
harmonic average of the Precision and
recall um this is the geometric mean
over the arithmetic mean um F1 kind of
gives a fairly accurate estimation of
what precision and recall if you care
both about it then um you may want to
use F1 rather than separately precision
and recall also there is another uh
measure fbaa which is actually the uh
superet of F1 um you could also use that
if you want to wait differently for
example I want my Precision to uh is two
two times more important than recall
then you could um compute the F beta
measure uh by putting beta equals 0.7 so
that um the Precision would be two times
more important than then the
recall um there is also F beta score in
the cyc learn which you could use um
also um for for the uh classification um
some of the um Ensemble models uh could
provide the variable
importance uh as well um I I won't spend
a lot of time on this um but if you want
to kind of explore which feature sets
are very important um for your
predictions um then it might be kind of
um a better practice to look at the
variables and then maybe the eliminate
ones uh that are not necessarily useful
for the classifier or you don't consider
very important um by doing so you would
uh eliminate some dimensionality
problems in here and um since the other
weights gets the um share of the not
important ones you may uh build a better
classifier although uh you could do
feature selection uh in order to
eliminate those um type of
problems um so the um in in this one um
uh the decision thre I think um um I'm
not really sure about the um how
gradient boosting uh handles but the
decision Tre is kind of try to locate
the distribution of the variables so if
um for example let's say we have a
categorical variable uh in
here um say um you know international
plan for example if um if there uh if
the international for example if all of
the international plan uh users have
turn problems then that variable that
variable importance would be higher um
because um it of
that um I'm not really sure for the
gradient boosting classifier but in
general um emble methods use either
entropy measure of that variable uh
regarding the class um or I think
there's another measure G um but uh for
the gradient Boos and classifier I'm not
really sure how how they are evaluating
it
what
cool and um after um you built the
features if if you um still uh don't
have the good uh set of features um for
your problem um py learn also provides a
polinomial features method which uh kind
of you could build uh pairwise
interaction of um of the raw features
and then after building that uh feature
set um which is a much higher Dimension
um you could also evaluate your
classifier based on the uh polinomial
features um you could also um scale the
polinomial features uh as well
uh similar to what we did earlier and um
regression um so I mentioned there is a
classification and regression problem
regression tries to Output um continuous
variables uh whereas classification
outputs a discret labels um this also
follows the very similar structure but
the data is um from Psy learn as well so
we don't do uh we I didn't do any
preprocessing in this one and um we
could could uh similarly use um gradient
boosting regressor and then um kind of
um try to locate the predictions and
labels and um in here there is an
important Point um so when you look at
the
um the um you could consider this as a
training error um this uh red curve is
the um test set um or validation set the
blue is the uh training set when you U
train the classifier the training Set uh
goes constantly uh lower and lower
whereas after some point the validation
set or the uh observations that we
didn't try the classifier actually stays
PR stable um this is actually this means
actually in here uh we are trying to
overfit and uh after that even if we
have a lower um training accuracy on the
data data data set uh that wouldn't
necessarily reflect on the accuracy on
the test set um so uh if you want to
kind of um try to optimize the cross
validation uh cross validation tries to
optimize actually U overall uh on the
validation set but you could also look
at the U separately training set
accuracy and the um cross validation set
accuracy for different parameters to see
the overfit
point
um so
when we train the like a classifier in
the cyc learn in order to get an optimal
accuracy it is um really like the TW
weing the parameters uh for the
classifier and um psych learn provides a
parameter search and uh module which is
uh called G search um based on uh some
parameters uh that you are put putting
um this is actually the regression
problem if uh if you want to try
different learning rates uh if you are
trying to you know different maximum
depths um number of estimators in the gr
gradient boosting regressor you could
create a garch u module which you
provide an estimator uh which is this
without providing any parameters and
then provide a parameter grid which we
will be looking at this grid for example
and then uh put the um X train and Y
train and then um this will provide do
um best score and also the uh best grid
uh parameters so that you don't have to
um manually try different parameters and
see um which one actually scores um the
best in the in the data
set
um the so um when we when we look at
parameter search um since these uh would
be the all of the permutations of each
learning grate maximum depth minimum
sample and so on um this number get
quite big uh if you have a lot of
different parameters for a model or if
you have parameters for preprocessing
steps then it may get quite big um cych
provides a randomized parameter search
module for that for that and um instead
of going through all of the parameters
it makes somehow uh smart decisions
about the distribution of the parameter
and then uh tries to pick the ones that
may uh result in um in a higher score
than uh than the others and uh in here
you could provide the total number of
iterations in order not to um in order
not to search for all of the parameters
in the grid but um for like for the
randomized search you wouldn't get the
optimal accuracy uh but if if you are
okay with local Optimum um and not
necessarily maybe do a lot of
computational work um randomized search
may also uh work quite
well uh for
you
um I I actually didn't run the um this
IP notebook but um you could you could
run it and then see the difference
between um how long it takes um both the
um randomized search and G search um
since I using the parameter grid I I I
think this would be a good experiment um
to see what what would be the
difference um so in the first one um in
the first notebook um we did a bunch of
uh steps we did a pre-processing step um
which is kind of um not really a feature
extraction but at least to build a
feature metrix and then we did a cross
validation step and then um based on
that cross validation step we did um an
evaluation
um in pyit learn there's a um subm
module pipeline which uh provides a
pipeline structure which you could uh
feed feature extractor feature selector
classifier and then deal with only that
uh single object rather than um rather
than doing a separate steps uh for
feature extraction selection and um for
the classifier which is um really easy
to use um Pipeline and uh classifier or
estimator class shares the same
interface so uh whenever um you want to
use a classifier you could actually use
the pipeline because um they both
Implement fit and predict under the hood
um so in this problem um we have um SP
spam uh H problem uh we have a a bunch
of um spam messages and also um these
are SMS messages um but some of them are
spam some of them are actually not this
is G binary classifi classification
problem um one may be to uh do first do
a um bag of words to create the feature
extraction and then put some waiting on
uh TF using tfidf Transformer tfidf so
that uh not all words uh get the same
weight and then uh maybe some classifier
uh to build the um actually the model um
but if you use the pipelines uh module
and put them uh into to a single uh
object then uh you could actually use
the same uh fit and predict methods that
you use in the in one of the classifiers
um with the with the pipeline and then
you could still uh do uh all of the
evaluation and um classification reports
on top of the pipe um this makes it
really easy or convenient to use um all
of the you know moving Parts in in the
uh machine learning pipeline you if you
want to kind of persist you could pickle
uh only the pipe rather than separate
separately uh pickle vectorizer um tfidf
Transformer and also the classifier um
which which makes it really uh
convenient to use uh in the production
um also when you um kind of output you
could still get the uh all of the steps
in a nice um topof list and then U kind
of refer and change uh uh in in there as
well if you kind of have a Pipeline and
then um there's some other classifier
that will be uh you want to change you
could um you could do that on the
pipeline object as well you don't have
to recreate everything and uh as I said
you could do pretty much uh everything
on the pipe object that you could do on
the classifier um these are kind of the
similar things that we did earlier you
could um create a confusion Matrix um
you could um create a classification
report
and so
on so um in the in the pre previous two
notebooks we did parameter search on the
classifier itself we have an um a basic
estimator and then do the parameter grid
uh on top of that uh the same goes to
pipeline as well but since pipeline has
uh multiple kind of steps we need to
have a better way to come up with how to
define parameters for each these steps
um psyit learn uses uh a python uh
convention to define those so if you
have a um so maybe I could actually talk
a little bit on this so
um when we
Define when we Define the um feature
extractor um the tfidf Transformer and
the classifier we are putting a string
on uh string to here in order to kind of
refer to this um objects and uh this is
uh for a reason uh when we do a
parameter G search we could actually
refer to this
um uh individual steps with a uh
following a double underscore to Define
their uh parameters for example um in
the bag of words count vectorizer
there's an engram range uh which
includes unigrams and byrams um which
you um which you could Define like this
and then uh when you create the um
parameters dictionary like this and feed
into the G search um Psy Lear knows that
these parameters are defined for the
count vectorizer these parameters are
defined for the tfidf and so on um so
that you don't have to kind of uh refer
uh each individual step separately but
you could kind of lump them all together
into one dictionary and then feed into
the um G search or randomize search in
this case um as I mentioned earlier pipe
could be used as pretty much uh where
you could use the classifier so you
could uh put the pipe uh in the first
and then par parameter distributions um
since we are using the randomize search
uh we need to also the number of
iterations in the uh that will be done
um in the in the randomized um search um
so this is actually um the best part um
I think uh in like building a pipeline
because not only you optimizing for each
classifier but also you want to also
look at the uh pre U the feature
extraction process and how tfidf course
would affect on that features um
features as well so generally most
people are doing the um optimization of
the parameters in the classifier level
but more often than not you need to also
tweak uh the features as well um by
using both Pipeline and also the G
search um in this structure you not only
uh optimize the classifier parameters
but also the whole pipeline the feature
extraction and if you are doing feature
selection or TF IDF waiting you could do
um in here and um and not necessarily
worry about uh how a biogram will affect
a barola classifier or random first
classifier
um um for different um feature extractor
models
and um for the random search or G search
objects you could get the best estimator
this returns since we are providing a
pipeline this will return a pipeline uh
which will which optimize the um both uh
the feature extractor method um and also
um for example he it didn't like the
diagrams and it dropped the diagrams
just using um bigrams boli has this uh
parameter set and so on um you could
also look at the U G scores this may or
may not be very useful um because I
think just computes the um accre scores
but you could feed into um
different um scores as well in the when
you create the randomized search CV so
if you want to compete fan score uh and
if you want to optimize for fan score or
Precision or recall you could um feed
into um the G search as well and then um
based on the outputs you could kind of
refer which uh uh which ones could be
more useful than the others rather if
you are if you want to also search for
the second best third best um this um
mean accuracies U would be also useful
for those
cases and um I think this in this
notebook this it and as I mentioned
earlier um you could um get the best
pipe um um with the um with the
parameters that we just learned and then
um create the um exrain and white train
which is actually pretty good
um and then the um classification report
um as
well um up to here does anyone have any
um question
okay um so um in CIT learn um there's
also another subm module feature unions
um up to here uh when we go to pipeline
um everything was sequential um so we
have a feature extractor uh which we
apply on some R text and then tfidf
waiting and then burn classifier and
then these steps will be done uh all um
kind of in a sequential manner but if we
want to B produce for example based on
some text bag of words and also for
example TFS scir of some text and then
concatenate them into one feature Matrix
um then the uh step ordering wouldn't be
really very sequential but rather kind
of parallel so that you would um extract
different features for each feature
extractor model and then kind of
concatenate them into one uh feature
vector
and then maybe do it uh in the in the
processing step um the feature Union uh
provides uh a structure on uh structure
on that so that um you could have uh a
bunch of
um
sorry um so that you could have a bunch
of very similar to the pipeline you
could have a bunch of different um Parts
in the module and then you could kind of
do PCA um on the r Matrix and then K
selection onto R Matrix again and maybe
do aernal PCA on the r Matrix and then
output of these each uh PCI module the
um the feature selection um using um K
selection um like 10 time features uh
PCA has two components we have two
components in here 10 components in here
if we were to use the kernel PCI we
would have three components in here and
then we could just run these each
individual steps since they are separate
since they are independent in a um in a
parallel par parall and then in a in a
parallel Manner and then um kind of
concatenate this feature Union into one
single uh feature vector and then use
that um in the uh in
the
classification um
the the feature Union is very similar to
pipeline it is actually uh under the
pipeline sub module you could do as as I
mentioned earlier you could do pretty
much um
do uh what whatever you could do in the
classifier you could do uh pretty much
everything um maybe I could talk a
little bit about um this problem but I'm
not sure if I would have sometime um
maybe um we could we could go over this
one as well um
um so this is um the um this is very
similar to actual CH problem uh we are
trying to predict if uh One customer
would get um would get uh a loan from
the bank or not based on um some other
um attributes that uh he has um the
preprocessing step is very similar we um
convert the um categorical variable
Ables using uh label encoder and we do
um a standard scaling and then um I kind
of um visualize what type of features
are actually correlated with with each
other and then U build um um extract the
PCA um the I values um in total number
of components to and um extract the T
best features um um by using S key um I
was using kernel PCA as well but um this
takes somehow um long to compute so um I
command thought and then um we could do
um we could train another classifier on
top of that um and then
um and then um produce the um
classification score on
that
um so up to um this point point I uh
mainly talked about uh like how do we uh
kind of optimize parameters for um a for
a parameters uh in here maybe I could
open this
one oh come
on
sorry about
[Music]
that
so up to um this point we generally look
at like just one classifier um one
feature extractor uh maybe some feature
selector and then um one
classifier but uh in generally uh if you
want to use
um
if you want to use um and if you want to
experiment with different classifiers
you need to kind of experiment with
different um
Pipelines
I
guess does anyone um can open on the
GitHub does
anyone I think I have some problems
huh it didn't Lo
yeah this
[Music]
interesting um I could I could
do yeah I could
wa it
works just to
wait so um yeah I could talk a little
bit about on that so if you want to use
um multiple U classifier multiple um
feature extractor and then compare them
uh you generally do this uh pipeline or
feature Union or the remaining stuff for
a bunch of um different um pipelines uh
and then uh evaluate um those pipelines
on each um each training uh set and
label
set um
the okay so um Cy learn and up to this
point uh like we we could do um cross
validation on uh each Set uh and then
maybe we could build um different
classifiers and then uh based on some
feature selection method um we could
kind of uh visualize how they perform on
the overall set um which uh with a
different um with a different number of
features and accuracy so
um this um problem is um actually
um
so um in this problem we have um text uh
text Data again and we want to classify
the uh Text data which uh each uh
different uh topics uh or um the classes
that uh New York Times uh
uses um but in instead of uh doing um
just a one classifier uh one feature
selector and one feature extractor
method we want to also be able to say uh
what type of uh classifier uh would be
best in terms of different number of
features um and uh using that uh we
would be able to choose the best rather
than um rather than just uh maintaining
only one uh feature extractor one
feature selector and one
classifier um this is uh not part of the
um psyit Lear but um you could kind of
uh since all of the classifiers share
the same interface uh you could uh
pretty much build um for different for
each uh individual feature extractor
feature selector um uh methods uh you
could apply and then see what would be
the output of of them uh in
the uh in the
output I think this is why um this is
this takes so
long anyway um um so this um does the uh
comparison um
between between each individual
classifier but maybe I could just drop
it yeah um there was another um graph
but um so in here um we uh we could um
if we were to use only one classifier
and then um see how that classifier
performs we could only choose that
classifier but now we could actually see
different classifi um with a variety of
um different number of features and so
on so uh for the uh model selection uh
this could be also another useful um
Step In order to compare different um
classifiers um pyit um originally built
built um on the data that you could
train when you fit into the memory so
all of the fit methods uh in the uh in
the psychic learn actually tries to load
the data into a memory and if it exists
uh the memory of your um computer then
actually uh it would uh produce a memory
error um recently I think it is uh 0.14
they started to implement this partial
fit function uh for a uh by of different
classifiers where if the classifier
doesn't necessarily uh need to load the
whole um observations or all of all of
the instances uh into a into memory uh
in one time then uh the classifiers that
use this partial fit function uh you
could actually use it and then um no
matter what the uh how large the data is
you could actually uh train your models
onto onto the classifier um since the
feature extractor methods or even the uh
maybe not feature selection but
generally feature extractor methods are
specific to each single instance so you
wouldn't have a a problem in that even
if pandas tries to load the data into
memory you may just do um line based or
observation based feature extraction but
generally the uh classifiers uh were the
hard part and um psych Lear provides a
way to do as well uh by um doing partial
fit
um and this is called out of core
learning since uh we can't load data
into the uh
memory um since this is a a relatively
new feature uh only these um five
classifiers um I think by uh 0.6 version
uh are implementing the uh
classifiers um incr yeah this is
incremental yeah um these are um all
incremental um there there's also I
think K means as well um but since I was
using just um the classification I
didn't include that
one yeah uh I think that will take some
time true right think but um for so in
Cy learn there are a lot of like
different SPM models so it is I don't
know um it it may be hard to do all of
the um spms to implement the um partial
fit but
yeah yeah um based on 0 point I think
um these are the ones uh
0.15.1 these are the ones that um that
are implementing but um they are like uh
putting more Focus onto to this area um
I I guess that so I'm actually um
comparing to here as well but they are
putting more focus on this area so I
guess uh at some point uh the ones that
could implement this type of learning
will will be uh implemented the another
nice thing about incremental learnings
is if you have a model in the production
and you want to tra you want to get you
get another new set of data you actually
need to retrain the whole classifier in
the psychic learn which is a little bit
problematic because you don't want to do
the all of the work that you did with
the incremental Learners you could um
train the model into um one like one set
of observations and then uh persist it
and then when you have a new set of data
you could kind of um use that model and
then use that new set of data in order
to improve classifier rather than going
through uh all of rather than going
through the all set and then load them
uh into memory which is um really nice
because um you you don't want to
necessarily do the all of the work that
you did um earlier um and then um in
here um you could
um um partial fit doesn't necessarily
care about the uh so when you when you
try try to fit uh on some classifier in
the psych learn it actually uh kind of
empties out the all uh all of the object
and then fits whatever uh X and Y is fed
into fed into the object partial fit uh
doesn't necessarily uh partial fit keeps
the state so if you uh in this uh line
if you put um this set of features and
then this set of labels and then in the
another step if you put another uh set
of features then
um as long as this is the new data
then um it is guaranteed to improve uh
the model and then um you could kind of
as you feed more data you could see the
Improvement as well on the um on the on
the
model um we actually have quite a bit
time um so for the deployment
um as as I mentioned earlier the
pipeline serialization is uh is Mak it
really uh easy to use um the psych learn
models um so if you
um so this is the um the preprocessing
step is not very important this is
actually the same with same New York
Times data um if you if you are not
using the uh pipeline uh subm module you
need to uh serialize vectorizer um and
the uh classifier um separately uh but
uh since p
uh combin those uh uh combin St steps uh
you could actually um uh like uh persist
uh by using the J sub module which is in
the uh externals uh module in the Cy
learn uh this will output a bunch of um
I think nonp array structure um into the
uh serialization path and then uh you
could easily um load uh the pipe and
then um that object is uh ready to use
um and then you could um kind of do the
uh prediction on the uh X test uh and
then uh get the predictions the very
similar in here um the J lip I think uh
uses uh pick link under the hood and um
pick link is not very secure and uh very
not very robust so if you are if you
have um like unsecure sources to get um
pickle data you shouldn't uh unpickle in
the python because it is not very secure
but if you are using only um like
pickling your your classifier or your
pipeline and then unpickle it um then uh
I guess it would be uh safe or secure to
use um the pipeline
modul um so job lip um if if you have a
if you have something similar to nonp
array um or um in general uh for example
you want to uh persist a feature metrix
um job lip is more efficient comparing
to pickle in terms of how uh it uh
inputs and outputs um pickling is good
for I think like General python objects
yeah for classifiers um
uh the one another thing is uh if you
um not sure about it but for some
different versions of psychic learn if
you are to use JP it it is preferable
because um like when you train like when
you train one classifier in
0.14 it may not work in 0.5 15.2 U there
is actually a warning in the psychic
learn J lip I I didn't have any problems
in the um JP um so that could be another
case in the py learn documentation um
the JP it says J is the preferred way so
um true yeah in the J plot um when you
get the serialization pet even if you
have like a thousand number of different
ire files J blot just does the work for
you under the so you don't have to go
through every single file as you
mentioned yeah that's also another
Advantage
um so in here um yeah the persistence is
uh relatively easy uh if you are using
um if you're using on the um if you're
using
pipeline um and also maybe I could spend
some time on the language detector so um
the the data set is in the load module
um it is not in the python notebook um
in here uh I have a bunch of
um um different uh language text Data I
think it is
eight yeah um that that are just uh
trained by Wikipedia um I get the
paragraphs that have um longer than
three sentences and
um if um if the um languages that have
uh English stuers in other languages for
for example Arabic or German um I I
removed those as well it is uh
relatively I would say good um a little
bit noisy and uh it is generally about
historical text because um I was doing
some historical text projects um and I
had uh this
um um project which uh post the data
from Wikipedia so um and in here um it
is um if you if you look at the data it
is pretty balanced I would say um every
2,000 instance we change the
language and um if we use a um tfidf
vectorizer um and put engram range 1 to
six um I tried different engram range
for this one but um especially after
four the um um performance gets really
better and um I use for analyzer chart
because um in the word level uh even if
there might be similarities in the CH
level um the accuracy would be even
better and um if we the pipeline
structure is very similar I didn't do
any cross validation in here um I I
separated the set
um with like cross validations split um
in this one and um and then provided
some um different um language sentences
and then it is pretty uh after you built
the model it is pretty easy to kind of
pass into a an um a number of uh
instances to the pipe and then get the
um predicted
languages um in this case every uh every
one of them is correct um you could also
look at the confusion
metrics um as well
um I think the German has some problems
in the or Chinese yeah German and
English has um quite a bit um overlap
and um but other than that um languages
like Arabic doesn't have
any
um misclassified objects and if you look
at the pr
um recall F1 score report um this also
um pretty good
um this the overall
um overall
tutorial if you have um any questions um
I have other notebooks as well if you
are interested in unsupervised learning
um I could talk a little bit about on
those as well but um sure you talk about
uh uh over fitting or how how do you
manage that or you have relatively lied
data you have you know the grid search
you optimize your parameters and so on
how do you get a sense until you have
much more
dat may
have yeah um sure so um in the cross
validation if you are doing uh like
everything right if even if you have
small data I think it it should be
pretty good because when you um train
the classifier since you are optimizing
the cross validation set and since that
set is not kind of seen by the
classifier I think it should be pretty
good but um you could do like maybe uh
create higher number of fults and then
evaluate um evaluate the classifier
based on the number of faults when you
have small data if like you know um I I
sometimes see when you create like five
FS 10 FS 20 FS I see a lot of different
classifier accuracies accuracy
differences and it might it may be due
to just because the labels are not very
you know balanced but also because um
some of the instances in some of the
faults are much more useful to the
classifier than the rest of it um you
could U deal with that also you may want
to decrease the noise in the feature
extraction maybe do like variable import
s or um how much each single variables
are actually contributing maybe removing
those would May provide a cleaner
feature metrix to the classifier to
learn that could be um also another way
to do it I guess
yeah
sure
mhm
sure um so if the um so the feature
unions are actually uh parallel out of
the box U you could kind of provide um
end jobs to the um even in the like
building feature set um since these
steps are kind of separate and
independent uh the and if you have the
you know processing power then you could
kind of par
this and the total number of it takes is
actually the slowest step in the whole
step so that you don't have to so that
you don't wait for PCA to complete KS
selection to complete kernel PCA to
complete but rather if kernel PCA takes
the most time then you could only wait
uh for the kernel PCA and the other the
rest of the steps will be done in the G
search um you could also optimize the G
search since those steps are pretty much
independent and SE separate but uh stuff
like for the classifier I think some of
the classifiers also support um like
parallel learning but not all of them so
in that in those case you are
constrained by the Learning algorithm
but other otherwise if like if the steps
that you are doing is separate and
independent you could do um like psych
learn provides a way to paralyze those
steps out of the
box
so I guess
um if anyone um has any
questions okay thank you
very thank you
[Applause]
very